よし、明日は運動会だ。今年は隣のブラック小学校と合道で開催する。やった運動会。俺は天才小学生やす運動会は大好きだ。運動。
ただブラック小学校はだいぶ手らしい。みんな頑張るように。
手ごたってたが知れてるだろ。
これより運動会を始めます。こちらブラック小学校の生徒たちだ。
ワクチンたちは
ブラック小学校組な。
[音楽]
なんだこいつら。
第1
種目は捜作ダンス。より良いダンスをした方が勝利だ。
[音楽]
ダンスは流行りの曲で審査員の目にとまるのが大事だ。行くぞ。しやししやしやいやし。
お先生、そのダース知ってるぞ。なんだりゃ。すごすぎる。
全国身体測定優勝常連のマッチプレザー。無闘能力は抜群だ。くそ。ダンスじゃ勝てない。こうなったら愛強だ。
可愛いだけじゃダめですか?
ダメってだ。黒組の勝利。ちょく
そ。あいつらやばすぎる。も本気で行かなきゃ。
第2
種目は大玉転がしを先に一周した方が勝利。よい。
[音楽]
大玉転がしは前に押すのではなく上に転がすと早く進む。
よいしょよいしょよいしょ。
そしてカーブの時は遠心力がかかるため減速してた方が早い。
[音楽]
まずい。子供いやれ。
よいしょよいしょ。
小学生相撲大会優勝者の子供力士。そのパーはい次元だ。て。反則だろ。
[拍手]
そっちが来るから体がぶつかっただけだよ。
くそ。何かないのか。
あ、誰もいないからリカないだ。
ええ。おい、勝手に触ると危ないぞ。ええ。
[音楽]
来た。
これだ。みんなエタノールを大玉に入れろ。ちょ
からてあいつらもう無理だよ。
ここにマッチの火を入れると
大玉の中の空気は爆発して熱包丁する。
おお、
ゴールが遠かったらここをゴールにすればいいんだ。お、赤ゴの勝利。マ
[音楽]
第3種目はためれ。
自の色の玉を遅れた方が勝利。よいし。
みんな上投げはやめろ。下から投げることでたくさんの弾を同時場に投げられるから攻撃的だ。
よし、行け。
お、
おりゃりゃ
おりゃ。
おっと。赤組がリードです。
まずい。必殺だ。やれ。
[音楽]
ほいほい。
おりゃ。おりゃ。ああ。えぐい。
おっと。黒組ボ追いついたぞ。
なるほどな。だがこれならどうだ。
うわあ。を雲に投げ入れることで水滴を決勝化させ雨を降らしたのさ。
おお。
行く場。行く場。
あれ?雨で滑るま。滑るまちょ。滑るま。
滑る。滑るま。滑る前。
いや、この雨を利用するのさ。パパ。
おいおい。パパに泣きついたて無駄だぞ。
滑る。
[音楽]
おっと。くる組。かが落ちて卵がゼロになってしまったぞ。
[拍手]
みんな。
[音楽]
雷は1番高い金属に落ちるのさ。わ、
パクチンのパパのプライベート機で雷を作ってもらったんだ。
ずるかしこさんは日本一の常をお父さんはとても偉い社長でそのサポートも最強だ。
それでは弾の数を数えましょう。
おっと、黒色の玉が23
個で黒組の勝利。木は向い競争だ。足に紐をつけたま学校の指定されたルートを取って入り口に先にゴールした方の勝利。
[音楽]
よし。
[拍手]
みんな足場大きくするとずれが起きた時に転びやすい。
うわ。マ、マ
[拍手]
できるだけは足場を新索して安定感を出すんだ。
おっと、赤大きなレです。
あ、みんな私
1きたい。
我慢してくれよ。
お、俺はいいぜ。
いや、別にしま、しょうがないから行くか。
おお。うわあ。え、取れないよ。
[音楽]
なんだあれ?
おき。マ、ママ、ママ、ママ、ママ。
[音楽]
これを子供力士に乗って滑らせるんだ。
すき。
この便女のせいでもう間に合わないよ。
ガーん。
待てよ。ここから下に下って玄関にゴールするだけだ。みんなでトイレをつまらせろ。うー。う。無理。プリプリ。
[音楽]
あ、赤勝利おめ戦だ。
よし、同点だ。勝てるぞ。
第5
種目は引きです。この印が自陣のラインを超えたら勝ちです。よい。お
お。
まあいいか。
お、パワーのそ歴子供にしけで勝てるよ。
[音楽]
ごっちゃんです。
俺の開発したマになろ。みんな貯めろ。
[音楽]
マチボイズエンゴー。
まちょ、マちょ、マちょ、ちょ、マち、
マちょがいっぱいだ。ちょ、
みんなで引っ張るぞ。ちょ、ちょ、ちょ、
[音楽]
ほら。僕たちの方がパワーは上だ。
そろそろかな。
え、なんで
[音楽]
月に縄を結んでおいたのさ。
な、何?
月は夜にかけてだんだん外に傾く。これで俺らの勝利だ。
ててて。
ええ、印が黒組の方に行ったので黒組の勝利
な。なんだって。
[拍手]
最後の種目はリレ対決。代表
人が走に先にゴールテープを切った方が勝利だ。点数は
2倍の100点。
要するにこれで勝った方が優勝ってことか。
みんな作戦通りに行くぞ。
さあ、レ対決始めます。よい
ね。マチなんでしょ?スクワット対決しようよ。スクワット対決はマとして断る理由がない。まちゃ
[音楽]
おら、こんなの簡単まちゃ。そんな細い体で持てるわけない。まちゃん
910。
お先すごすぎ。まちょ。あのダンベル聞いたのは偽物だ。
[音楽]
910はい
はい
ま
[音楽]
おっとマっちょブラザーズ何豚じに追いつくぞ
まっちょく
何き
これで相手も1コだ
あごめんね
女の子より男の子の方が好きなんだ。ゴー。はせ。
ま、僕のリードだ。
すぐ追いつくけどな。このために開発したスーパーモビルスーツだ。
うわあ、
すごすぎ。
僕も準備してるよ。パパが秘密りに開発した
UF用意したんだ。
えぐいて。
うわ、
人は互いの速さを証明することに夢中になり、ついには戦いの場を宇宙空間に移したのであった。
どっちだ?あ、
[音楽]
ええ、2
人が高速を超えた時、時空が歪み、地球では
[音楽]
年の時が経っていたのだった。ま井先生の墓
まさかまさか久しぶりに会えて嬉しいわ。
70年ぶりじゃの。
ま、まさかお前こじり懐かしい懐かしい僕の運動
[音楽]